[Música]
[Aplausos]
la llegada de la creatividad
computacional nos proporciona nuevas
herramientas que amplían el horizonte
del arte en mi caso particular la
composición musical para ello hemos
desarrollado algoritmos que emulan el
comportamiento creativo y que al mismo
tiempo nos ayudan a ahondar en la
comprensión de nuestra propia
inteligencia
desde la neurociencia cognitiva margaret
boden nos señala tres tipos de
creatividad humana la exploratoria que
fuerza los límites pero sin salirse de
las reglas un caso sería la música de
johann sebastian bach la combinatoria
que fusiona campos y disciplinas
diferentes para generar nuevas ideas por
ejemplo la arquitecta zaha hadid que se
inspiró en la pintura de kazimir
malévich y finalmente la transformadora
implica un cambio casi siempre radical
de las reglas de juego un ejemplo sería
la emancipación de la disonancia por
parte de arnold schönberg y su sistema
de composición donde crónicos
podríamos definir inteligencia
artificial término que acuñó yo a un mac
karthy en 1955 como la capacidad de un
sistema para interpretar y aprender a
partir de un conjunto de datos
y utilizar esos conocimientos para luego
abordar tareas y metas concretas de
forma flexible en el terreno de la
composición musical la inteligencia
artificial está abriendo nuevos caminos
y es algo que está muy presente en mi
manera de componer
desde pequeño
he tenido una gran pasión por la ciencia
en mi proceso creativo la utilizo como
generadora de material musical que luego
incorporo a mis obras este proceso tiene
dos pasos fundamentales en un primer
paso género material musical a partir de
esos modelos matemáticos científicos y
en un segundo paso utilizo esa materia
prima para componer mi obra un poco como
el escultor utiliza los materiales el
hierro el mármol la madera
el pintor los pigmentos que son materia
prima pero no son en sí una obra de arte
para crear sus obras de arte
en el año 2000 escribí el programa de
composición algorítmica freeware fractus
que proyecta
en matemáticas a conjuntos de parámetros
musicales que luego a mí me sirven como
materia prima para generar mis obras
fragmento ha sido una herramienta
fundamental y lo sigue siendo en mi
proceso compositivo a continuación os
quiero poner un pequeño ejemplo de una
obra que utiliza fragmentos para generar
este material musical es el preludio de
mi sonata para viola y piano
otra fuente importante de generación de
estructuras musicales en mi obra son los
fractales los fractales son objetos
matemáticos que muestran auto similitud
a diferentes escalas
son una rama de las matemáticas que
describe con gran precisión numerosos
fenómenos naturales como pueden ser las
plantas a lo largo del tiempo he
desarrollado una técnica compositiva que
consiste en convertir imágenes de
naturaleza fractal
a parámetros musicales que luego utilizó
en mis obras nos muestra un ejemplo de
uno de mis meta lúdicos para piano que
utiliza una imagen fractal la que
estamos viendo ahora mismo en pantalla
para generar todo el discurso musical
incluyendo la forma
[Música]
entre 2009 y 2012 colabore como
investigador y principal asesor musical
en el proyecto y amos que es el primer
ordenador capaz de escribir una
partitura en notación musical compleja
sin intervención humana y ambos utiliza
algoritmos bioinspirados para generar no
solamente fragmentos musicales sino
obras completas
en 2012 el proyecto culminó con la
grabación de un cd con obras
íntegramente compuestas por llamas que
incluía música de cámara y una obra
orquestal de gran formato que interpretó
la london symphony orchestra
en mi ópera la casa imaginaria que se
estrenó en 2018 utilice fragmentos de
llamas como material musical como
materia prima musical para componer la
obra muestra un pequeño ejemplo del
inicio que usa uno de estos fragmentos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
e
[Música]
la experimentación musical con los
últimos avances tecnológicos es algo que
me apasiona y ahora mismo estoy usando
el machine learning como herramienta de
composición musical a través de magenta
y magenta es un proyecto de código
abierto enfocado a las artes que utiliza
el di planning o aprendizaje profundo
para generar nuevo material estos
algoritmos basados en redes neuronales
aprenden de un conjunto de datos
previamente dado y una vez entrenados
son capaces de generar nuevo material
que imita y está basado en ese mismo
conjunto de datos para ello utilice todo
el corpus de obras de piano que tenía en
ese momento todos mis metal u2 para
piano que eran 29 obras
unas dos horas y media de música y una
vez entrenado el algoritmo
a partir del modelo resultante genere
cientos de fragmentos entre cuatro y
cinco minutos después de un proceso de
selección y curación pero sin modificar
nada de lo que había generado la máquina
decidí quedarme con tres que titulé cien
saints forget gate y long short ser
memory este último me talud yo lo
interpretara para ustedes en estreno
absoluto al finalizar la charla fruto de
esta simbiosis hombre máquina ahora
estas tres tres obras forman parte de mi
catálogo de obras de piano
como compositor estoy realmente
sorprendido y fascinado porque en ellas
puedo escuchar reminiscencias de mis
otros metal metal u dios es evidente que
el algoritmo ha aprendido de ese
conjunto de datos y ahora es capaz de
generar material musical que me imita
que escribe en mi propio estilo aunque
sé que técnicamente no lo compuesto yo
hay un sabor un
de mi música en estas piezas estoy
convencido que el driver ning va a
suponer una revolución profunda en la
actividad creativa de los compositores
el debate hombre humano es ya muy
antiguo creo que debemos superar el
miedo y los prejuicios que la
inteligencia artificial puede suscitar y
apostar por la ayuda que nos brinda no
solamente como herramientas sino como
fuente de inspiración si además tenemos
en cuenta el impacto en la creatividad
exploratoria y combinatoria quizá
estemos ante un nuevo tipo de arte
me ilusiona ver cómo funciona la
inteligencia artificial como nunca
puedes prever exactamente o ni siquiera
de manera aproximada qué va a suceder a
continuación siempre hay sorpresas y eso
como compositor es lo que me mantiene en
movimiento muchas gracias
[Música]
ah
y
[Música]
ah
aquí
[Música]
a
ah
[Música]
y
i
[Música]
y
[Aplausos]